hey David California's primary has been
moved up by three months from June to
March what impact will this have
specifically on the 2020 election
assuming that Donald Trump remains the
Republican nominee for 2020 okay so yes
March 3rd 2020 I believe is the new date
of the primary in California if Trump is
the Republican nominee the primary in
California really is going to matter
only insofar as who wins the Democratic
primary you still will have Iowa New
Hampshire Nevada and South Carolina
having their primaries before March 3rd
which is the date California will have
their primary along with a bunch of
other states Alabama Massachusetts North
Carolina Tennessee Oklahoma Texas
Vermont and Virginia so a few different
things to keep in mind number one
California does have a history of moving
around their primary even though
recently it has been in June in 2008 the
California primary was in February
they've had it at different times over
the last several election cycles the
impact could actually be significant for
a few different reasons number one if
you win big in California on March 3rd
that can have much more of a momentum
setting impact than it would have to
have California determine the result of
their primary in June so California
could play a much bigger role in
determining who the Democratic nominee
and ultimate challenger to Donald Trump
is going to be that's number one number
two remember that California allocates
delegates proportionally so if you get a
plurality of the California primary vote
with say it's a five-way primary with
34% you don't get all of Californians
Delic California's delegates you get 34
percent roughly of those delegates or as
closely as they can be sort of sliced up
so although there is importance to
California moving their primary up
because of that momentum setting agenda
on the other hand remember that unless
you overwhelmingly win California it's
not necessarily it's not likely to be
the deciding factor in who ultimately is
the Democratic nominee you've still got
to do really
well in the subsequent primaries in
particular in 2020 there are two primary
ways primary that the California primary
being in March could impact the
presidential campaign in general number
one if Kamala Harris runs senator from
California there is a case to be made
that if we assume she would do
particularly well in her home state that
having an early California primary is
good for her specifically that may not
ultimately be the case because
California is a major Democratic
fundraising stronghold stronghold could
be good for establishment Democrats with
more name recognition it could be good
for a more progressive candidate like
Bernie Sanders or Elizabeth Warren
although not all of California is that
progressive so I don't know but
potentially if Camilla Harris is a
candidate that could be an important
factor for California having an earlier
primary the bigger picture though is
that it's going to be really tough to
unseat Donald Trump I mean in general
it's just hard to defeat incumbent
presidents we've talked about this
before george w bush is a recent example
with everything going wrong in a failed
war in iraq still unable to be defeated
although we could say it came down to
foul play in ohio and a hundred and
forty thousand votes but that being said
it was close enough that that made a
difference so having a much longer
period of time having eight full months
if indeed we know who the Democratic
nominee is going to be by the middle of
March which we may we may not as a
result of this that gives a full eight
months to have one candidate running
against Donald Trump is that better
probably it's also a longer period of
time during which that candidate can
make errors during which that candidate
can be successfully smeared but that is
an important dynamic for unseating an
incumbent president particularly one
like Donald Trump who is appealing to
people not on the basis of what he's
actually doing but on the basis of
basically weaponizing disinformation
calling anybody who disagrees with you
fake news citing accomplishments that
aren't real
congratulating troops for a pay raise
this week that is imaginary so those are
a few of the thoughts I have about
California moving their primary up I do
want to hear from you what do you think
the effect will be of a three month
earlier California primary